[Music]
there was an explosion and he likes the
gone bro I just love to hear what it's
meant to you to you know to step into
the into the life of this man right here
yeah well you know what he made me
realize is I think that inside of us all
is a superhero you know I'm gonna be
there at the finish line Flay doesn't
show up for anything
he shows up inside of us you know in in
the darkest times in in times where we
feel like you know or people who we love
that we're close to are going struggling
through something you know that we can't
get through it we won't make it through
another day or another hour or a minute
or a second that we can that there is
that thing inside of us and playing a
character like that in a film was an
opportunity for me to learn that about
myself and see my own faults and see my
own weaknesses but also as Jeff reminds
me everyday see my own strengths you
know in places that I never thought I
could be strong being identified as a
hero was something that it seemed that
you were resisting so what's it like for
you to hear that now where are you with
that now well Jake said you know Jake
Jake said this heroes and all of us but
yeah I try to I deflect it because I
have so many heroes in my life around me
you know out of me it's hard for me to
accept that sometimes that I'm a hero
but you know if the zeros everywhere how
does anyone pass up on Oprah at that
point in my life I was like you know
there's so many things coming at me you
know and then I have my mom oh we want
to do Oprah gonna do Oprah I just want
to focus on my recovery and then stuff
like that but this movie about those
private moments yeah those moments when
nobody's watching you know those moments
you know Jeff said something in a
Facebook post
the other day said doesn't have to make
headlines to be hard you know and I
think I think that's those are the
moments when the people who really love
you are there and that's what this
movies about is the people in the
community around you who love you
getting you through how do you do it as
Boston accent listen up this young lady
here is running the marathon for
bringing a we're his hospital great yeah
we joke around a lot we joke around with
it
[Music]